c'était la rentrée pour les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux dans leur stade
jean maréchal lésigny montain recevait
le paris uc pour leur premier match de
la saison en d1
une rencontre fermée qui a vu les
yvelinois s'imposer 1 à 0 grâce aux
vénézuéliens ronnie materno elias est en
train d attendait un à samarra
spécifiques et mais là la cia vient
frapper il est fait un triplé et après
les lieux il a fait un pas ce vol il ya
marqué les bras un match l'autre
vénézuélien s'est également illustré son
nom au yoyo francs que lopez lui des
cinq recrues du club attiré plus d'une
centaine de lancer pendant la partie
relancé en tout cas sur un monticule il
a maîtrisé vraiment beaucoup mieux que
le lanceur adverse
au niveau des stray cats il a une
dizaine de strakka pts donc il a
vraiment maîtrisé son match malgré la
victoire le staff espère voir l'équipe
progresser offensivement pour atteindre
les objectifs du club une place dans les
trois premiers et une qualification en
coupe d'europe
il faut vraiment quand ce calibre c'est
un début de saison donc je leur laisse
le temps de s'habituer au retour c'est
vrai que c'est pas évident non plus de
revoir des des lanceurs un peu plus
rapide puisqu'en pro quand saison on n'a
pas eu affaire à ce genre de lanceur
donc c'est vrai que le temps de dax il
faut qu'ils se il faut qu'ils règlent
akouala faut qu'israël et ça va lire
dans la deuxième rencontre de la journée
face au puc eux les y montrent un se
sont une nouvelle fois imposé de
justesse 5 à 4 prochain match le
dimanche 15 avril sur le terrain de
savigny sur orge
en attendant les couillard peuvent
savourer